say it's interesting start 2018 there
was a lot of chatter on Twitter and
other social networks about how there
was a sort of a lot of patches going
into the Linux kernel was what I think
the started people noticing this and
that perhaps there was a major exploit
about to be announced that would affect
Linux perhaps and actually as it turns
out windows macros and other operating
systems and well the short of this is is
that people at Google and various other
universities Rambis and res other
institutions and so on have discovered a
way that any program can pretty much
read data that it's not meant to be
reading that can be anything as simple
as reading a value past the end of an
array even though the program is coded
just not let you do that
which gonna give you access to data that
you shouldn't have in your program to up
to in the worst case being able to read
kernel memory which is your operating
system everywhere these things like
passwords and encryption keys stored to
actually reading the whole memory of
your computer in the worst case to make
it worse the really nasty thing about
this one is it's not a problem in the
software as such it's a national problem
with the way that modern CPUs are
implementing whether it's AMD Intel arm
as on they've all said that in certain
circumstances all their CPUs could be
affected so it's a pretty major thing
which is going to require some
rethinking perhaps of the way the CPUs
are designed the best comment I've seen
about this is the u.s. is certain
computer emergency response teams
article on this which I've got open here
yellow he says CPU hardware
implementations are vulnerable to side
channel attacks these 400 ridges are
referred to as meltdown and Spectre and
they says solution replace CPU hardware
the sort of thing that so it's pretty
major so the short of it is is that you
can now even though the operators are
saying you can't even though the program
is saying you can't you can read memory
that you shouldn't have access to and
then use that to exfiltrate data from
the computer system that perhaps you
shouldn't have access to and according
to a Zillow and crime and things there
are ways that this can be done via
JavaScript say on a webpage so you could
technically I don't if it's blunted yet
but the real danger would be that you
could go to a webpage and it would copy
out all your memory very slowly we
should admit over the network and people
would have access to things it's not as
bad as it sounds there are things that
can be done in software that can patch
and sort of mitigate the effects of this
and stop it happening the downside of
that is that they can have a significant
sort of speed performance hit your
programs will probably end up running
slightly slower and slightly depends on
what it's doing how it's actually
interacting with the operating system
and so on but as the cert says to really
fix this it's going to need to require
redesigned CPUs the big thing here the
very big difference between this and
other exploits we've covered because
every exploit seems to be the biggest
thing since sliced bread the biggest
thing is this the fact that it's
Hardware right yeah so this is not
something that can be directly patched
in with a new version of the software
you can switch from Windows to Linux or
Linux to Windows to Mac OS whatever is
rabia FreeBSD dragonfly BSD open BSD
whatever your favorite operating system
of the month is this is an attack that
is fundamentally in the way that the
CPUs have been designed to work and
doesn't even require the operating
system it can be done if you can get the
code to work say from a bit of
JavaScript on a web page and there are
examples that have been shown to do that
as far as I see in the media there's
spectra and there's meltdown is it are
they completely different things then
what or is it just that they affect
different devices or how does it work
so they're basically they're all
variants of the same techniques the way
of exploiting the design of a modern CPU
to access data that you shouldn't have
access to the best way to think about it
is that spectrum describes
sort of family of different techniques
or exploiting the way the CP is designed
to have access to 80 perhaps shouldn't
have access to meltdown is a specific
instance of using one of those
techniques specifically to access the
kernels memory and from that to be able
to get access to any sort of memory
inside the computer at that time so
they're all related and they sort of all
work in a similar way so we'll dive down
in a minute and have a look in the paper
that as benders released describing the
way the spectra sort of attacks work
there's some demonstration code which
I've got here again it runs the same on
Mac Windows Linux you take the same code
we've alter the different things it's
completely independent of the operators
and this is right down at the CPU level
what we've got is we've got a function
which is accessing an array of 16
elements so we have an array and it's
called array one which has got 16
elements in it and they are set to be 1
2 3 . up to 16 so accessing in this
array and they're laid out in memory
we've talked about that in previous
videos this is an access by a variable X
which is used index that array but the
program says if X is less than 16
accessing array if it isn't it's not
going to access the array or program it
specifically written in a way so that
they won't access for all these past the
end of the array however by using this
attacks described in what's been termed
Spector then you are able to still get
the values in this case the string that
I've changed from the examples we hello
computer file and so if we can pile this
up and run it what we should see there
just make it slightly bigger is we
should see the message hello computer
file pop up so it's getting the data of
various things and we see here a hello
computer file is popping up and if you
go and grab that you can grab the code
look at the paper in a sitting there at
the back now this isn't anything too
spectacular it's one program accessing
data with inside its own progress plates
why is that an issue well the
interesting thing is that what we've
managed to do we've been able to do this
by accessing a value that we shouldn't
be able to access this code this if
statement should stop us being able to
access this past the end of this array
yeah as we can see there the message
hello computer file is a parent
appearing and this is a problem because
this could actually be done say from
JavaScript on code that's being
downloaded from a web page and so one
web page will be able to say pull things
out of your web browser that perhaps
have been loaded from another web page
say your bank details or something so
that's one possible way that this could
be exploited so the way that Spectre and
meltdown work is that they take
advantage of two features of a modern
CPU the way they design the way that
actually implemented so we've talked
about how they're running our machine
code but underneath that's getting
converted into the electronic circuits
which execute that and firing them off
at the right time and modern CPUs take
advantage of two techniques one of which
is called out of order execution and
basically what this means is the CPU
will reorder the instructions well
technically a reorder that microwatts
that the restrictions get split up into
but that's going even more days and we
need to to find the best way to execute
them to make keep everything going and
running at the best speed on top of this
we get what's called speculative
evaluation which basically means that
the CPU is going to execute code even if
it doesn't need to necessarily do that
the best example if we go back to the
code that we were running here this
program has got a bit of code and I've
run it down here the bit small so
beautiful bit which is actually values
from array 1 with an index of X but
before that we check that our X is less
than the size of the array and if it
isn't this code doesn't get executed so
what the Spector need to do what
specially needs to do two things one it
needs to have this value bit of code
executes even though it shouldn't to try
and get those values from our message
out of there so that's the first thing
it needs to get this bit of code to
execute even though he shouldn't and two
it needs to get the value returned from
that out and pass it so you can actually
extract that value and get that value
that it was trying to read so it's two
things that it needs to do and it can do
for those things by exploiting the way
that a modern CPU is designed because a
modern CPU actually is designed to
sometimes execute code even though it
doesn't need to or rather we have a
technique which is called speculative
evaluation and what this will say is
okay I am going to execute this code
because there's a very good chance and
it might need to be done but it might
not and if it doesn't I'll undo what
that code did and then execute the code
that should be done so for example an
example where this might happen in this
code is if we didn't know the value of
array one size we didn't know it was 16
so we hadn't actually got that value
good you have to go off to memory and
get that value if this had to go off to
main memory rather like anything from a
cache it would take 200 times as long to
access it from main memory so about 100
nanoseconds as opposed to half a
nanosecond on a modern sort of typical
modern CPU so it'll take it a reasonably
long time and so what the CPU will do is
while it's waiting for that value it'll
make a prediction based on what's
happened before based on the way this
branch has happened before about whether
it's going to execute this code or not
and so it may well execute this code
even though it doesn't need to because
it thinks it's going to do in fact
there's ways that spec to use is to set
that up so that that actually happens so
the modern CPU will execute this anyway
and then throw the result away so how do
we get the value out of it well actually
if you look at the code that's being
used it's not just getting the value
from this it's actually then using that
value to access another array and it's
actually multiplying this by 512 why is
it doing that let's see what this act
gets exited as well 1s is this memory
it's going to fetch and again we're
talking about the cache it's going to
fetch in the whole cache line containing
that thing into memory and put it into
the cache so that will then get cached
what that means is that the next time
it's accessed that value is cached as
they'll be exit very quickly as opposed
to very slowly again about 200 times
difference is speed there's a way you
can use the cache as a sort of covert
channel to transfer information out
based on whether something has been
cached
or not and as it turns out even though
the result of this is thrown away the
fact that this then access to the cache
and brought that value into the cache
line is not thrown away so the cache
actually has that value in it and so you
can use the speculative evaluation to
cause this instruction to get executed
and actually get the value for memory
and then you can use the cache as a sort
of covert channel to get that value or
parts of that value out of this thing
where it's actually thrown away and you
never actually see it into something
that you can then extract and if you
look at the rest of the code you'll see
they're things where it's flushing the
cache and timing how long instructions
take to run so it's calling the function
and then it's looking at how long
instructions to access to find out which
value was cached and so which one is
accessed quickly and that is based on
the value that was returned and so if
you can find out which bit in memory was
cached
you can effectively use that as a proxy
to find out what the value that was
returned was even though the CPU threw
that value away and so the specter and
meltdown or rely on the fact that the
CPUs will sometimes do work they don't
have to they will speculate and say well
actually there's ways you can force that
to actually be more likely to happen by
setting things up in the right way and
if you read the perfect paper you can
see how that's done so it uses that to
cause it but normally that would be
thrown away but actually unfortunately
the way the modern cpus are designed is
that it's possible to set things up so
they leave a footprint in the cache
about whether they accessed a value or
not and you can then see what the value
was returned so it's sort of clever way
of extracting the values and they do it
perhaps a bit at a time or a byte at a
time
and they can actually what meltdown does
it does the same thing but it actually
it sort of manages to get the data out
of the kernel address space because of
the way the caches are implemented and
the way that the sort of protection
checks are done the speculative
evaluation can sometimes happen before
the protection check happens because of
the way the server's can actually be
reordered to make things work as best as
possible so yeah
not good probably need a new CPU just
reading between the lines even though
everybody's blowing up about Intel at
the moe
actually the medium to longer term
problem is is all CPUs there is a big
the moment Intel has a problem because
meltdown specifically isn't its and
that's the effect and the mitigation so
it will slow down the way computers work
significantly in some cases this
technique expected does work on other
CPUs as well the sort of doing these
things
AMD arm Intel have all said that in
certain circumstances there are ways
that they're affected so I suspect we
will see a few more plays on this in the
next few years
by using this sort of idea of a
superscalar project we can actually have
multiple instructions if they're in the
right order that sort of using different
parts of the chips and so on we know
multiple instructions execute at the
same time and then you can say well
actually if we can do that we can start
to actually put say two ALU bits in
which do the addition and so on we can
have to add instructions providing
they're separate